this isn't so much about trying to
actually hack the iphone as much as just
testing the limits of face id how far
can you stretch it before it fails
it's not working
what's really neat about the new iphones
is that they have this feature called
face id which allows you to unlock your
phone using just your face that's secure
enough claimed by apple that you can
have a million different faces and will
only ever recognize the one true face
what makes face id really interesting is
how it recognizes your face through a
variety of methods a proximity sensor
has an infrared flood light projector
that essentially projects thousands of
dots those sensors are all there right
in that notch how good is this face id
tracking
[Laughter]
what's up i'm saying like you can change
your look you can wear makeup it'll
still unlock leads me to think that all
that matters is the geometry of the face
nico thinks that color doesn't matter at
all does he first off does it use the
selfie camera at all so there's the rgb
camera right there right uh-huh i'm
gonna cover that up
and unlock my phone
so obviously it works with niko's face
but we thought let's try it with a
different face who looks like nico you
and nick look kind of similar so i want
to see if your face up recognition on
your phone will work on nick eyes are
important because there are two separate
security features one allows your eyes
to be closed the other one requires you
to be looking at your phone it unlocks
with his eyes closed the eyes are not
required for this mode
ready
nope
i'm not surprised that it didn't work on
nick from there we'll try other things
like cover his face with various things
we tried putting a t-shirt over nico's
face that didn't work we tried putting a
trash bag over nico's face and that
didn't work either that one i was
curious about because
trash bags that certain type of plastic
is actually transparent to near infrared
nothing
because uh i mean the thing about
stretching it over your face is that
it's rounding out all your features what
if we just got your face really wet and
shine the light on it i'm going to go
change t-shirts
this went for a swimming dip and swim
and dip it works so shininess doesn't
matter paper mache let's paper mache
your face beard
what's your favorite color black it was
like it's not a color it's abs it's the
color you could what was your
combination
toyota
corolla 1988. when did you get that car
when i was in high school it was in 1988
it was like 2002. these aren't the
security questions i ever use in my
accounts you know
it's not even detecting a face so it's
like if you ever get like really badly
burned
let's try that
no oh
yeah let's give you some lips
let's see how much i need to take off
before it works
it worked
it's interesting the only thing he needs
is this
yeah this is probably all scanning right
here bottom of the chin doesn't matter
so we wanted to find out if face id
worked through a reflection aka a mirror
so let's try that right here
it worked
it didn't work totally worked oh wow
wow
yep
even that was with attention mode turned
on yeah
interesting
i mean theoretically as long as you have
a good mirror it should be
indistinguishable to the phone
nope it's measuring this area here
it's a little stash it works
because it doesn't use the rgb camera it
doesn't take color into account yeah
infrared can detect luminance changes it
can detect contrast but it can't
actually detect the difference between
like blue red or green because of that
we thought we might as well just either
paint niko's face entirely white or use
something a little simpler and easier to
clean flour we have cornstarch or we
have baby powder choose your poison
baby powder
okay try and go
all right did not work
[Music]
who's calling me somebody's calling me
it's alex beavets all right now now try
face id you're right no hold on let's
see if this works i'm gonna i'm just
gonna blow some off of your
face oh it jiggled did it work no
[Music]
oh that's interesting i can't get into
my phone now oh wait i know how to fix
it
clean off your
brows i thought apple said if it were
makeup it wouldn't make it so i couldn't
get my phone i mean does baby counter oh
it worked let's get it in my eyes
whoa
that looks so weird as soon as he wiped
it off it went from white to now the
more contrasty darker color of his
eyebrows and as i mentioned the infrared
camera cannot pick up color but it can
pick up contrast aka his white skin
versus his dark eyebrows apple claims
that you can have a mask representation
of the real face and it will not work
niko and i were talking and we realized
we actually wanted to test whether or
not a 3d printed mask would or would not
work with face id
i'm literally just going to use my
iphone 7 to take these photos
3d scan of nico's face from the scanning
program i brought in the 3d smacks and
actually cleaned it up all right here's
the zero hour one hour two hour three
hour eight hour 10 hour 14 hour 18 hour
22 hour 48 hour 56 hour done
it'll use 146 grams of plastic
[Music]
and matterhackers has 50 of these
printers
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
everything we just filmed the mic wasn't
working enjoy us talking about it while
you look at all the b-roll footage we
literally just captured here's the
here's the raw 3d printed model how does
the scaling look so that was the biggest
issue here is we had to make it the
exact same size as my face so i think it
might be just a tad bit too small just
like a tad bit and i worked really hard
and trying to make the scale perfect all
right
so we tried to understand if we tried to
scan the 3d model with my phone it's not
unlocking but it is it is acknowledging
that it's a face so what we're going to
do next is to help shade things in right
yes when we covered my face in baby
powder which proved to be a more
informative test than i thought it would
be we discovered that when it couldn't
see my eyebrows
it didn't unlock and i think it's
because it's using the black and white
feed from the infrared camera to just
try to detect some basic features such
as eyebrows and eyes using a pencil here
to fill in because the
little ridges on the plastic actually
pick up the pencil really well this is
it starts across a threshold of getting
kind of creepy like i'm holding my face
in my hands it is it is a little creepy
nico
all right let's see if this is enough
i'm so nervous
i don't know it's shaking his head no no
no no
it
it might be like half a percent too
small
yeah and that could make a difference
it's you know it's interesting because
the the scan
worked well enough for the phone to
identify that it was a face but it also
was not enough to fool the iphone into
unlocking and that could be due to a
variety of reasons for instance after
doing this whole print i learned that
pla plastic is technically transparent
to the wavelength 940 to 950 nanometers
which is in near infrared imagery maybe
it's it's seeing that the face is
actually kind of transparent and being
like well obviously that's not a real
face because we're getting these really
weird results
i don't know here's the thing though i
have seen youtube videos online there's
this vietnamese dude for instance who
managed to 3d print of his own face out
of a color print i think it was like
sandstone or something like that and
then he actually put infrared picture
cutouts of his eyes on the print itself
and that was actually able to fool the
iphone even with
required attention turned on i'm left
with this failed experiment and i'm left
unsatisfied because i want to see this
through all the way so maybe early next
year we can revisit this experiment and
actually do the same steps that the
vietnamese guy did and hopefully we will
be able to fool nico's iphone with a
better 3d print
my favorite people are our patreon
supporters this month i'm doing the uh
the verbal thank you but with a twist
actually going to spin in a circle like
this for 15 seconds before i can say
thank you to you so for every name i'm
gonna have to spin oh
i'm not gonna catch you if you fall
oh god this is already such a bad idea
okay yeah you're done
richard linder thanks
okay this was the first one
[Music]
corey o'malley
thanks it makes me lean
for sean this is for sean witt
sean witt thanks dude
i think i could do it one more
oh that's no bueno
[Music]
you did it
[Music]
oh i'm still spinning
so hot gly
yeah you still got somewhere on the list
how far am i
uh
i'm halfway through
13 14 15.
taylor
dunbar oh
run
brian antosik
richard blackburn thanks guys sorry i
wasn't able to spend for your names ah
that was bad i'm never doing that again
ren i have a science question for you
ooh i like science definitely worth
asking red i think it's a question i
want a professional opinion about it so
the question is when a goldfish is in
the water is it wet or is it dry when
it's fully submerged there's no air
you're asking if a fish is wet so let me
ask you this is it a thing when you pull
goldfish out of the water are they dry
no are they i think that's the way it
becomes wet the debate is it only
becomes wet is when it's been pulled out
of the water but if it's fully submerged
you guys are crazy if you're submerged
in water you're obviously wet or you not
become wet until it's because of your
wetness is contact with water everything
in the ocean is wet but how do you know
you're wet if you're completely
submerged because how do you know you're
wet if you're completely
you're you're how do you know
if you're not doing anything for the
rest of the day do you want to come
guest star in a spyfall episode for node
yes you started saying that you are wet
when you're submerged under water we're
still on this oh he's still on this
yes
how
you're saying the definition of wetness
is the absence of dryness that's what
you're saying i have to go fill node man
you're going to ruin